le tourisme régional a tout pris son
envol au québec depuis que le
gouvernement a fait plafonner à 500
dollars les prix des billets d'avion en
régions éloignées c'est un pas important
pour l'industrie touristique est un
point important pour l'industrie
aérienne régionale difficile à dire pour
l'instant faute de données mais déjà des
acteurs du milieu par un effet limité
l'impact n'a pas été notable surtout des
membres par exemple nous ont mentionné
qu'il y avait vraiment un et pâques du
1er juin au 15 août et neuf mille quatre
cent soixante et un billet aller-retour
qui ont été vendus dans le cadre du
programme d'accès aérien aux régions
programme qui rend disponibles
annuellement 98 mier de 800 billets
de manière générale paul airlines qui
offre plus d'une vingtaine de connexion
au québec et dans l'est du pays nous
avons vendu plus de billets vers des
destinations régionales comme sept-îles
on a vu une augmentation de
1,7 cette année on semble avoir tué des
gens issus de tous les milieux là qui
vont
la reprise des voyages et du terran
rabais sur les billets d'avion en
régions éloignées et isolées
pour expliquer cette tendance explique
l'union des municipalités du québec en
étant sa difficile de trouver un vol à
certains moments donnés durant l'été
tellement les vols étaient remplis
et pour le professeur meyrannes ibrahimi
investissement de 90 millions de dollars
sur deux ans de la coalition avenir
québec n'en vaut pas la chandelle
sincèrement je pense que c'est le
gaspillage de l'argent public est
souvent serait de sièges n'a jamais créé
l'an comment ni dans pour les régions ni
pour les compagnies aériennes alors que
le gouvernement entend stimuler la
demande de vols régionaux certains
intervenants demander ce qu'il y ait
plus d'hôtels plus de transport et plus
de flexibilité sur les heures de vols à
l'aéroport pour mieux accompagner les
visiteurs dès leur arrivée aux quatre
coins du québec
ici gabriel propre radio canada montréal